welcome back to Facebook organizer I'm
joined by my Super PAC first time these
three have been together talk to Elise
International editor Isabell oakshot
talk to your contributor Paula Ron
Adrian and the comedian his words of
mine James Barr welcome to all of you
wow it's just a little gate James to get
you in the right Spirit um I want to
play a little tribute before we get to
the pack to one of Britain's greatest
ever actors and I use that phrase very
deliberately Sir Michael Gambon has died
aged 82.
um so many things you could say about
him it just had an amazing career
amazing range he was one of the true
greats that our theater has ever
produced and of course did many great
movies and so on I once interviewed him
at the National Theater
um where he played many a great role and
I asked him what he thought of the
increasing malaise sort of talentless
zedless celebrity wannabes trying to be
stars and he went you know all I've ever
wanted to do was act I remember sitting
in this very dressing room after my
first hit here and people outside
applauding when they saw me at the
window and that was so exciting it's
what I wanted recognition of my work
there were all these modern celebrities
want is a quick buck with no Talent or
hard work required it's awful
so I said to you what would you call
this type of person
and Sir Michael looked at me and smoked
and said I would call them a
rip Sir Michael you were brilliant on
stage and you were brilliant off it to
interview
um a great actor
I want to talk about uh another
theatrical story
Cinderfella the Scottish ballet is doing
what everyone does now they're taking a
very popular classic fairy tale which
obviously is about a woman identifying
as a woman
um and they're going to switch it rounds
apparently audiences won't know
apparently from nights might be very
exciting whether it'll be Cinderella or
Cinderfella uh to which my point is
suppose why can't we just leave this
stuff alone why do they won't forget you
have to come for everything why did that
to ruin everything what's a degender
change gender abuse gender why can't
they just leave us alone these people I
can't Cinderella be Cinderella do you
know something really weird this was
actually first done in the 60s yes there
was a thing called Cinderfella yes a
Phil I think Jerry Lewis yes this is not
a joke no well it was satire was it but
it's not yes so this isn't even original
that I'm going to actually surprise you
and say I actually think this oh oh no
you've gone I think he's gone we've lost
you I wouldn't take my kids to it you're
supposed to be on this pack as a voice
of Common Sense come on it's quite
entertaining I mean yeah it's not quite
like that element of Jeopardy is it
gonna be Cinderella wait a minute Isabel
you wouldn't take your children come on
of course you would I'm joking yeah
it's rubbish it's just a tendency James
all right James I know what you're gonna
say why why are you bothered but
actually it's a really important thing
because it's flipping the narrative and
making the guys what's the narrative so
it is because it's turning the guy into
the victim who needs saving yeah and
ultimately we all need saving
particularly you right now on this
planet well why don't you love this
upside down realm where everyone is
doing you could actually play one of the
ugly sisters finally your dream role oh
you came to play didn't you oh but I'm
serious though we talk about masculine
toxicity and here we have the classic
example why aren't you supporting
why don't you want men to be vulnerable
why don't you want oh man
oh I've changed I'm just saying my men
being vulnerable but you know what I
love most in the world I like a stiff up
a British I like people who don't spend
their entire time their entire time
absolutely up to here with the victim
culture that we now have to endure well
everyone's a victim weakness is
celebrated
strength is a problem right everyone has
to be in mode 24 7 to come into work did
you not ask the question
why let me ask the question why why why
that sounded like a victim to me do you
know who's strong Teddy is not a victim
is not a victim Mick Jagger right who's
80 years old uh still doing his thing
amazing uh really physical freak to be
still prancing around doing that I mean
look at Joe Biden by comparison
about eight months of age right
um Mick Jagger has announced he's not
going to give his money to his eight
kids he's got apparently 500 million
dollars right I I like that idea if my
kids are watching I really like that
idea because why would he give why would
you give Isabel all that cash to young
people before they've even tried to make
their own way in many of the cases of
his kids some are still very young why
remove all hunger I feel like I know
we've done that too I know people have
given their kids loads of money very bad
idea it kills the hunger yeah and
without a hunger and desire to make that
money for yourself I think you end up
with just a wasted life I completely
agree with you I am going to assume that
he's leaving them something they
probably already have assets whether
it's property whatever but absolutely if
you make life too easy for your children
if they don't actually have to feel a
bit of a struggle then there's nothing
to get up for and they you know it was
uh they drift around they flop around
yeah I talked to Cristiano Ronaldo about
this right and we had dinner one night
after interview the first time and he
was saying that you know he is his son's
very good at football the old his oldest
son and he said he's very very good but
he can't give him the hunger that he had
he was literally hungry he used to sit
around the back of a McDonald's and two
lovely ladies he said I wish I could we
tried to find them but we couldn't
um they used to give him the cast off
that's problematic yeah we should give
the cast off Big Macs right and he said
that was how hungry I was so everything
was driven by this intense desire to get
out of that cycle he was in of hunger
but when his son that's now got a dad
worth a billion dollars probably right
you can't give that doesn't mean to say
he won't develop his own desire and
hunger so much harder to instill it in
someone right I would just say I'd like
to pick up on what you said there
because you were commending Mick Jagger
for jumping around on stage at his age
yes but you wouldn't say that about
Madonna so I didn't know because she
it's the way she dresses and the way she
humiliates and leading on from that I'm
not actually concerned whether Mick
Jagger would give leave his children
money I mean Jerry Hall Bianca Jagger I
mean these are strong women uh you know
they are there supporting the children
so this isn't really about Mick Jagger
leaving history it's more about a
principle yeah I do think I've seen
people leave their kids too much money
and they just they just remove any
incentive how much money are you leaving
your kids fears very little right
actually well I say very little I'd like
to think I can help them in some way
right I would like to remove from
everybody right never mind my kids but
anyone's kids right I'd like to remove
the stress of having no money I think
the stress of not being able to feed
yourself or feed your your children or
your family or whatever that is one of
the worst stresses in the world outside
of bad Health right I think this is the
ultimately the problem with this article
because Mick Jagger can sit back and
laugh about how he's not going to leave
he's very comfortable children more
money they don't need it be interesting
to know what he is going to do with it I
don't know whether he's revealed that he
said yes if he might give it to
Charities you might do some good in the
world yeah well that's that's okay for
an lgbtq plus charity
hang on what did you call it LGBT
what happened to the two oh goodness me
we're the twos yeah they're there no no
you didn't say two leave me alone
thank you I really think I mean
obviously by tomorrow there'll be
another one but at the moment it is it
is Q2 plus so I know that and I'm
surprised we should cancel him maybe
well maybe honestly well hold on a
second I thought you caught the woke
mindfulness
myself I've identified as two businesses
I'm actually personally taking that very
badly you're saying you're half black
and half white no I'm a tooth fairy
penguin uh well I think we all are a bit
I have an idea I have my DNA Done Right
zero English Okay zero mainly Irish a
bit of Scottish uh they charted me back
to Robert the Bruce
um a little bit of Welsh a little bit of
Middle Eastern quite a lot right but
absolutely sorry and a lot of misogyny
[Laughter]
zero English very interesting yeah and
yeah I was born in England Scottish
would feel about that so I'm I'm
thinking that we're on a work work due
to Scotland to watch the ballet right no
we're not right we're going to talk
instead about it's it's calling somebody
woke as bad as a Rachel slur actress
Kathy Tyson said in an interview with
the telegraph for me it's as bad a term
as an offensive racial slur the term
woke and race guard are deeply offensive
to me so the latter is thrown in your
face if you make a criticism of anything
so here's something James I don't think
it is because I wrote a whole book about
this I identify as woke by the original
definition which came from the American
music business in the 60s and it was
about raising awareness of Social and
racial Injustice I absolutely by that
criteria I'm a woke person right what's
happened is woke has become hijacked by
a lot of social media mobs in particular
and they use it as a form of fascism now
to basically try and make everybody
conform to their way of thinking that's
my problem with it see I found that
interesting because I actually think
it's that but also so the opposite of
that in that people use it as a slur to
say to undermine your other things
become a slow by definition because the
people in that woke world who identify
themselves well I'm not so sure why
you're blaming woke people for that
because a lot of them I think are
actually worthy of condemnation for
propagating the nonsensical views they
have and then expecting all of us to
agree with it you have actually used the
word woke about me as a slur you've
called me a wokie right exactly so in a
way you're that's because you propagate
woke uh thought processes which are
ridiculous so you think it's ridiculous
to like stand for race stand against
race no but if I ask you for example
should biological males be allowed to
compete in women's sport obviously what
would you say this is a crazy question
that I'm not here to talk what would you
say it's because it's not something I'm
not an expert I know also you don't want
to say because you know what you would
have to say to fit the criteria of being
a wokie you would have to say you agree
with it and in that moment everyone
watching at home goes we're a complete
literacy then you're a one you're a
wokie by the common definition today
she's a complete classic of the genre
isn't she because she's going on about
how deeply offended she is and that is
the whole thing about wokery it's
continually about people being offended
offended by everything causing a fence
and then and everyone everyone and I
mean so she swallow Brotherman have been
deeply offended by Gary lineker's tweet
I don't think she should have been but
she told us that she was she told us how
outrageous
well I don't think even you think he was
suspended first I don't think even you
as a black woman can feel comfortable
that calling someone woke is as bad as a
racial slur come on uh it what the point
is and it's a point that I agree with
with James and pick up on it's used now
as a pejorative isn't it it's used to
itself
yeah I don't think it is when it's
deserved I think it's just thrown out
there for anybody who happens to say
hang on a minute is this thing no I
would say 99 of people that I call woke
in a in a derogatory manner deserve it
because they've been ridiculous so it is
a slur you agree
ment
the woke world view of life I find
ridiculous right utterly ridiculous
therefore I'm using it as a term of
mockery abusing someone about their skin
color is a completely different and in
my view far more serious thing so why
are you using the word work why don't
you stop using the woke
and say that what you are saying what
you're saying is nonsense because it
really annoys the workers yes
I feel really proud of being called woke
because it means I'm trying to make the
world a better place
people make the world a worse place they
make it a joyless ridiculous humorless
affectionate so everybody has to look
the same sound the same say the right
things absolutely can't crack anything
blah blah blah it is disgusting I agree
we finally agree how could you possibly
think that we all want each other to
look the same when we're all about
inclusivity you know I've just realized
looking at you sitting in that chair
you're the new Richard ties thank you
although I couldn't think of anybody
that sounds like a less light Richard in
the entire world
that definitely felt like a slur to be
honestly
yeah in about a minute when you go off
there you're going to realize why Isabel
may not see that as a slow are you aware
that no oh right oh tell me what what
have I missed oh they're an item oh
really yeah
all right which is fine but you know you
might feel a little uncomfortable now
right no well no which is great because
I didn't get offended
I made it it was a moment of
excruciating mortifying embarrassment
for James Barr and that's always a good
way to finish a pack great to see you
come back soon James thank you